ce n'est pas la star du rock johnny
hallyday qui a été récompensé hier soir
mais l'acteur qui a reçu le prix jean
gabin 2003 johnny qui confie volontiers
que sa première intention n'était pas de
chanter mais de jouer la comédie mais
qui ne m'aiment pas de regrets pascal
deschamps eric de lannion intimider
jusqu'au dernier moment johnny et il ne
jouait pas la comédie dans la star
incontestée du rock'n'roll à la
française n'a jamais considéré que la
notoriété suffisait pour faire de vous
un bon comédien ni à vous mettre sur les
rails du succès au 7e à son jeu dans
l'homme du train lui a valu et pour la
première fois un concert de louanges et
une quasi unanimité des voix du jury
face à des acteurs d'une autre
génération est normalement après qu'en
donne aux jeunes alors je me suis dit
bon c'est bien à trouver
c'est énorme monde ah bah pour moi il a
bercé toute ma jeunesse j'ai vu tous ses
films et s'est taillé pour moi c'est un
grand facteur donc d'avoir le pris en
plus de gens là bas j'ai vomi lamy je
peux vous demander quelque chose tu as
bien sûr vous pourriez me prêter des
pantoufles et pourquoi vous fait mal aux
pieds j'aurais jamais porté c'est sur la
pointe des pieds que jean philippe smet
débarque sur les écrans jeunes élèves de
simone signoret dans les diaboliques de
clouzot
il avait dix 10 ans plus tard celui qui
voulait être acteur est devenu l'idole
des jeunes et le cinéma milliards pas
longtemps le phénomène
les propositions pleuvent le plus
souvent des bluettes sentimentales à
l'après 7 dans lesquels on lui demande
surtout de chanter pour moi le cinéma je
crois que c'est une évolution dans ma
carrière et en plus de ça chauffe ça
tombe bien parce que j'aime beaucoup le
cinéma j'aime beaucoup la comédienne
évolution pas tout de suite car dans les
années 60 et 70
le cinéma ne lui offre que des films
dans lesquels il joue son propre rôle ou
jouer avec son image de gentil mauvais
garçons comme il le dit lui même
c'est une scène où john berry explique a
à d et comme dans la vie il faut marcher
détenus et là on a une cascade à faire
il faut consulting brigade tu aimes les
40 motos thiem les casquettes que j'aime
bien je veux que sexy il lui faudra
attendre des réalisateurs comme resta
gavras ou jean luc godard pour que le
public les critiques et peut-être
lui-même découvre le comédien hallyday
dès lors il n'arrête plus tourner
n'hésitant pas à dire oui à de jeunes
auteurs hallyday prend des risques et un
tournant lentement avec la modestie qui
le caractérise c'est pas facile face à
des chanteurs connus d'être crédible
aussi des vagues
donc je fais tout pour ça je choisis des
rollers en général qui sont totalement à
l'opposé de ce que je suis en tant que
j'ai une dernière question est-ce que
vous avez adopté les pour tous les
charentais n'ont pas encore que c'est la
fin du journal et dans un instant la
météo présentée par patrice drevet 20h
david pujadas on se retrouve demain à
13h un excellent après-midi sur notre
chaîne
à demain
le